so you had a chance to listen to what
the president had to say and also this
new idea that investigators are looking
into the possibility that the Afghan
citizen but US citizen as well so
obviously born in Afghanistan and US
citizen that he might be part of a
terrorist cell what more do we know
Megan so there's been several
developments in the past hour one is
that there has been an altercation in
Linden New Jersey where the suspect I'm
economy has been taken into custody it
appears after a shootout with police in
Linden we also have you know increasing
information that this suspect was not
only connected to what we saw in chelsea
in New York and the undetonated device
but as well as an earlier bombing early
on Saturday and also in New Jersey and
what it looks like is that the same
person may have been connected to the
series of incidents on the second hand
we also don't know much more about the
motive we don't know that more about his
family we have cops in New Jersey
investigating his house we do know that
and we but what I think investigators
will be trying to piece together now
what we know they'll be trying to piece
together is what are his links does he
have any connections to foreign terror
cells foreign terror plots what's he
been reading what's he been looking at
what's on the internet and what is
family history and sketch that out in
greater detail